Canlarım benim. Benim 9. sınıf biricik
öğrencilerim. 9. sınıf matematik marif
model konu anlatımlarına ahan da bu
video ile beraber startı veriyoruz. Ama
bir iki hemen hızlıca söyleyeceklerim
var. Bu söyleyeceklerimi hemen
söyleyeyim. Ondan sonra da ders
anlatımına geçelim. Arkadaşlar şimdi eee
bir video paylaşmıştım. TAF 9 tema
anlatım fasikülleri ile anlatacağım. 9.
sınıf matematik Marif modeli. Bu bir
kitaptır ama tamamen ücretsiz. piyasada
falan hiç satılmayan tamamen sizler için
oluşturduğum ücretsiz bir ders notu
kitabıdır. Bu kitap şu anda fasiküller
halinde yazılıyor. Ben yazıyorum.
Yazımlar bittikçe de arkadaşlar sizlere
PDF'leri paylaşıyor olacağım. PDF'ler
ilk yazılıp çıktığında e hatta sadece
tflar değil biz eee yazılı öncesinde
genel tekrar PDF'leri, prova yazılı
PDF'leri vesaire bu PDF'lerin tamamını
da ben önce Instagram'dan duyuruyorum.
çıktıkça hani sıcak sıcak fırından
çıkıyor ya bilgisayardan çıktığıyı alıp
hemen Instagram'dan linklerini
duyuruyorum. O yüzden Instagram
kullanıyorsanız Instagram'dan takip edin
ki duyuruları anında PDF'leri, ders
notlarını eksiksiz almış olun. Tabii
sonra videolarını çekince YouTube'daki
videoların açıklama kısımlarına da
ekliyorum. Instagram kullanıyorsanız
Mert Hoca TV kullanacağ adım. Bu
videonun açıklama kısmına ve yorumuna da
Instagram eee adresini etiketliyorum.
Şey yapıyorum, yazıyorum, sabitliyorum.
Oradan takip edebilirsiniz. eee,
PDF'leri ve ders notlarını takip etmek
adına önemli. Şimdi biz ne dedik? Biz
TAF 9'la anlatacağız 9. sınıf matematik
Marif müfredatını bu sene. TAF 9
ücretsiz bir fasikül kitabıdır. Tema
anlatım fasikülleri açılımı. Eee,
piyasada yok. Hiçbir şekilde satışa
çıkarmayacağım. Bununla alakalı
arkadaşlar ayrıntılı bilgiyi çok detaylı
analizi işte dersler nasıl olacak,
videolar nasıl olacak, PDF'ler ne?
Bunların bütün hepsini ben TAF 9. sınıf
matematik yol haritası videosunda
paylaştım. Önce o videoyu eee merak
ediyorsanız lütfen bir izleyin. Ben
çünkü bu videoda onlardan hiç
bahsetmeyeceğim. Direkt dalacağım. E
ders anlatmaya giriş yapacağım
arkadaşlar. O videonun da açıklama
kısmına ve yoruma sabitliyorum o
videoyu. E merak edenler 9. sınıf yol
haritası videosunu izleyebilirler. Şimdi
öncelikle biz 9. sınıfa şöyle bir kuş
bakışı bir göz atalım abiciğim. Şimdi 7
tane temamız var. Hayırlı uğurlu olsun.
Ellerinizden öper. Yi tane tema. Boru
boru değil boncuk iç değil. 7 tane tema.
Şimdi birinci temamız sayılar
arkadaşlar. Sayıların dör tane alt
başlığı var. Birinci alt başlığımız üslü
ve köklü sayılar. Ben bu videoda üslü
sayılara başlıyorum. Üslü sayıların şu
anda PDF'i tamamen hazır. Bakın biraz
şimdi azön birazdan fasikül de
göstereceğim size. Üslü sayıların şimdi
sizlere tek PDF'ini vereceğim. Bu
videonun açıklama kısmına bakarsanız
komple bütün üslü sayılar tek PDF
halinde sizinle paylaşılıyor olacak. Ama
tabii ki ben tek PDF'i bir derste
anlatamam. Zaten sağdan bakın
görüyorsunuz. Üslü 1.1 üslü sayılar. 1.1
üslü sayılar. 1ci ders artık üslü
sayılar anlatımına bağlı kaç ders
sürerse bence 56 derste üslü sayıları
paket ederiz gibi duruyor ama yine de
belli olmaz. Eee üslü sayıları eee
anlatmaya başlayacağım birazdan size.
Sonra köklü sayılar gelecek. PDF'leri
arkadaşlar videoların açıklama
kısımlarından da dediğim gibi
Instagram'dan da duyurulardan da takip
edebilirsiniz. Ara ara ben zaten sizlere
PDF'leri sürekli bu PDF yayınlandı.
Köklü sayı PDF'i yayınlandı. Birinci
fasikül tamamen bitti demiş olacağım.
Bakın 7 tane temamız var. Hemen şeyi de
göstereyim size. TAF programımızı da
göstereyim. Bakın 9. sınıf. Şu 10la 11'i
boş verin. 9. sınıfta arkadaşlar 7 tema
var. Biz 4 fasiküle böldük 7 temayı.
1inci fasikül sayılar, ikinci fasikül
nicelikler, değişimler, 3üncü fasikül
geometrik şekiller, eşlik benzerlik. Bu
iki tema var 3üncü fasikülde. 4üncü
fasikülde ü tane temayı kapsıyor.
Temaların yoğunluklarına, kazanım
yoğunluklarına, uzunluklarına göre
fasiküllere böldük. Birinci fasikül 3
aşağı 5 yukarı hazır ama bütün
kontrolleri bitmeden sizinle
paylaşmayacağım. Zaten okul şu anda yeni
açıldı. O yüzden siz şu anda üslü
sayılar e PDF'inden ilerleyebilirsiniz.
Ben fasikül tamamen bittiğinde de
sizlerle PDF halinde paylaşmış olacağım.
O zaman şimdi ne yapıyoruz arkadaşlar?
Üslü sayılara başlıyoruz. Hadi bakalım.
Şimdi üslü sayılar PDF'imiz burada
arkadaşlar. Gördüğünüz gibi TAF 9'un
kapağı. Tabii şu anda 1inci fasikülün
kapağı ama 1inci fasikül daha bitmedi.
1inci fasikülün birbiri yani gerçek
sayıların üstlü ve köklü gösterimleriyle
yapılan işlemlere dair muhakeme
yapabilme öğrenme çıktısının üssü
sayılar kısmını sizlere başlıyor
olacağım. Şöyle bir genel anlamda üslü
sayılara da bir göz atalım.
Bu arada 9. sınıf yol haritasında
ayrıntılı bahsettim bunlardan. Kavrama
noktalarımız var. Öğrenme çıktılarımız
var. Süreç bileşenlerimiz var. Uygulama
sorularımız var. Dikkat noktalarımız
var. Senin sıran yani sizin çözeceğiniz
sorular var. Beceri temelli sorularımız
var ve bağlam temelli sorularımız var.
Ve arkadaşlar ne yapmış olacağız? Cevap
anahtarıyla bitirmiş olacağız. Cevap
anahtarı da eee her eee konunun sonuna
toplu bir şekilde eklendi ki eee
erişiminiz kolay olsun. Tamam mı? Peki.
Şimdi ben bu videoda üslü sayılara
başlayacağım. Bir yerde kalacağım. Bir
sonraki derste de kaldığım yerden devam
edeceğim. Siz yapacağınız ne? Videonun
açıklama kısmına girip bu PDF'i çıktı
alacaksınız. üslü sayıların tamamını
çıktı alacaksınız. Eee, bir ders notu
dosyası oluşturmanızı istiyorum. O
dosyanın içerisine bu çıktı aldığınız
bütün dosyaları, eee, şeyleri, notları
dosyalayın. Böyle bir ders notu dosyanız
olsun. 9. sınıf matematiği beraber
alalım, yürütelim, götürelim. Tamam mı?
Seviyorum sizi. Hadi bakalım. Peki o
zaman üslü sayılarla, üslü sayın, üslü
sayıların tadımıyla başlayalım. Hadi
bakalım. Gazamız mübarek olsun.
Bismillah diyoruz. Şöyle bir bir çay
içeyim önce çünkü önemli bir eşik. Derse
başlıyoruz.
Evet [homurdanır]
zaten eee
şeyden
8. sınıftan üslü sayının ne olduğunu
biliyorsunuz. O yüzden geçiyorum
buraları diyormuş. Hiçbir şey
anlatmıyor. Siz zaten biliyorsunuz
arkadaşlar. Öyle bir öğretmen modeli var
ya. Bunu biliyorsunuz. Bunu yaparsınız
zaten falan. Şimdi üslü sayı nedir?
Şimdi tanımımız şu. A 0'dan farklı
gerçek sayı ve n pozitif tam sayı olmak
üzere a üzeri n ifadesine üstü gösterim
denir. Arkadaşlar ardışık bilmem kaç
tane sayıyı çarptığınızda bunu böyle
amele gibi yazmazsınız. Mesela 102 tane
a sayısını çarptığım zaman a x a x a x a
x a yazmak yerine biz bunu kısa bir
gösterimle 102 tane a'yı çarpıyorsa a
üzeri 102 diye gösteriyoruz. Bu gayet
basit. n pozitif bir tam sayı olmak
üzere dikkat ederseniz a x a x a x nokta
nokta nokta a kaç tane a burada önemli
kaç tane olduğu n tane a o zaman ben
bunu a üzeri n ile gösteriyorum bu.
Şimdi eğer eee n pozitif bir tam sayı
olmak üzere a üzeri -n formatındaysa
örneğin a üzeri -3 gibi bir şey varsa o
zaman da biz bunu şöyle yapıyoruz. 1 pay
paya geliyor. Paydaya sayıları çarpmaya
başlıyoruz. İşte kaç tane a'ydı? 3 tane
a'ydı. O zaman a x a x a yapıyoruz.
Olay bu. Yani negatif kuvvette 1/
pozitifte yaptığımızın aynısını
yapıyoruz. Aslında olay bu. Tamam mı?
Bununla ilgili bir uygulama yapalım.
Aşağıda [homurdanır] verilen üstü
gösterimlerin değerlerini hesaplayınız.
Tamam. Hesap böyle kibar sorduğun sürece
hesaplarım. Problem yok. Şimdi 2 üzeri 3
ne demek? 2 üzeri 3 tane 2'yi ardı
ardına çarp demek. Ne oluyor lan? Beni
netlemedi kamera. 3 tane 2'yi ardı
ardına çarp demek. Hemen çarpalım. 2 x 2
x 2. Hemen çarpıyorum. 2 x 2 4 x 2 8
finito çok. Devam ediyorum. 5 üzeri 4.
Eyvah.
4 tane 5'i çarpacağız. 5 x 5 x 5 x 5. 4
tane 5'i çarpıyorum ardı ardına. Tamam.
Çarpalım. Ne yapar abi? 5 x 5 25. 25 x 5
125. 125'ten
625 yapar. Bakın bunları bazı
arkadaşlarımız ezberliyorlar. Aman
diyeyim yakarım. Bunlar ezberlenir mi
oğlum? Saçmalamayın. Bunları ezberlemeye
falan 5 üzeri 4'ü ezberlemeye falan
gerek yok. Yaz çarp lazım olunca yani 7
üzeri 2. 7 üzeri 2 ne demek? 2 tane 7'yi
çarp demek. Yani 7 x 7 yap demek. 7 kere
7 kaçtır? 49'dur.
Tamam. O da güzel. 3 üzeri 5. Oba 3 x 3
x 3 x 3 x 3 yani 5 tane 3'ü çarpacağız.
3 x 3 9 x 3 27 x 3 81 81 x 3'ten 243
Aslında o kadar da korkulduğu kadar zor
değilmiş. 2 üzeri -3. Bak -3 diyor.
Hemen şöyle yapıyorum. Bu eksiden
kurtulayım abi. 1/ eksidden kurtuldum
artık. 2 üzeri 3. Bu da 1/ 2 üzeri 3
demek 2 x 2 x 2. Yukarıda bunu
konuşmuştuk 8'di. O zaman buranın cevabı
neymiş? 1/8'miş. 3 üzeri -4'e geldim. 3
üzeri -4 ne demek? 1/ 3 üzeri + 4 demek.
E o da ne demek? 1/ 3 üzeri 4 3 x 3 x 3
x 3 3 x 3 9 x 3 27 x 3 81. O zaman
burası da ne yaptı? 1/81 yaptı.
Mükemmelsiniz siz ya. Kurban olsun hocam
size. Tamam. Bak bunların hepsini
hallettik. Şimdi bu tarafa gelelim.
-2 üzeri 3. Bu sefer eksi şeyde aşağıda.
Tamam. Ne demek bu? -2'yi 3 kere çarp
demek. -2 x -2 x -2. Tamam. -2 x -2 + 4.
+ 4 x -2 -8.
-5 x -5in karesi yani -5 x -5 -5 x -5 ek
ile eksin çarpımı + 5 kere 5'in çarpımı
25 + 25 -3 üzeri 4 e -3 x -3 x -3 x -3
değil mi? Ne yapacak? Eee burada şöyle
yapabilirsiniz. Önce işareti bulun.
Zaten 3 üzeri 4'ün 81 olduğunu
konuşmuştuk az önce. Bak 3 üzeri 4 81.
Buranın cevabı 81. Baba ya + 81 ya -81.
O da işarete göre bakacağız. Eksi 4 tane
eksi var. Çift adette eksi var. Bak eksi
ile eksinin çarpımı artı artı ile
eksinin çarpımı eksi. Eksi ile eksinin
çarpımı artı. Yani burası + 81. Buradan
şu ipucunu da almış oluyoruz aslında.
Bak, negatifin çift kuvvetini aldığın
zaman pozitif çıkıyor. Negatifin çift
kuvvetini aldığın zaman pozitif çıkıyor.
Ama negatifin tek kuvvetini aldığın
zaman negatif çıkıyor. Demek ki üslü
sayılarda yeni bir eee çıktı. Yeni bir
eee kavram ortaya çıkardık. Negatiflerin
çift üssü pozitif, negatiflerin tek üssü
negatif. Birazdan onu da göreceğiz
zaten. Şimdi -1 üzeri 6. Ş. Şimdi -1
üzeri 6. Şimdi zaten bu şu demek. -1'i 6
kere çarpacağız. Yani şöyle yazayım bir
kere. -1 x -1 x -1 x -1 x -1 x -1. Şimdi
bir kere 6 tane -1 olduğu için artı
olacak. Şöyle de değerlendirebilirsiniz.
Bu eksi bunun çift kuvvetini alıyoruz.
Dolayısıyla buranın cevabı artı olacak.
Ne kadar 1'i kendisiyle çarparsanız
çarpın cevabı hep 1 bulursunuz. 1in
kendisiyle sürekli çarpımı her zaman 1'e
eşittir. O yüzden buna da + 1 yazdım.
Güzel. -2 üzeri -4 hocam -4 de + 4 gibi
+ 2 gibi çift. Bu eksiyi artı yapacak
mı? Yapacak tabii ki. Göstereyim mesela
nasıl olduğunu. Eksi olunca ne oluyordu?
1/ -2 üzeri 4 oluyordu. Şimdi -2 üzeri 4
ne demek? Pratik olalım. Bir kere bu 4
çift olduğu için bu eksiyi artı yapacak.
2'nin 4. kuvveti de 16 olduğu için bura
+ 16. Burada da 1 var. 1/16. Gördünüz
mü? Yapıştırdık. Buraya gelelim. Şimdi
bu eksi kuvvette üst tarafta olduğu için
biz bunu 1/ -3 üzeri + 3 diye yapacağız.
Bu 3 tek kuvvet olduğu için buradaki
eksiyi yok edemeyecek. 3'ün 3. kuvveti
de 27 olduğu için cevabımız -1/27 olmuş
olacak. Bakın bütün alıştırmaları, bütün
uygulamaları güzel güzel tane tane
yapmış olduk. Tamam mı? Şimdi bir
kavrama noktamız var. Kavrama noktası
şunu söylüyor. A 0'dan farklı bir gerçel
sayı olmak üzere A'nın 0 kuvveti 1'dir.
Yani her sayının 0 kuvveti 1'dir
arkadaşlar. Sadece 0ın 0 kuvveti
belirsizdir. O başka bir şey. Ama onun
dışındaki bütün sayıların 0 kuvveti
1'dir. 7'nin 0 kuvveti 1'dir. 12'nin 0
kuvveti 1'dir. -3'ün
0 kuvveti 1'dir. Sayı eksi de olsa artı
da olsa 0 o sayıya ait bir kuvvetse
sonuç her zaman 1dir. Tamam mı? Peki bir
sayının herhangi bir sayının 1inci
kuvveti kendisine eşittir. Çünkü 1ci
kuvvet demek hiçbir şeyle mesela 2inci
kuvvet kendisiyle iki kere çarp demek. E
1inci kuvvet hiçbir şeyle çarpmış
olmuyorsun. Dolayısıyla her sayının
1inci kuvveti kendisine eşittir. Devam
edelim. A negatif bir sayı olmak üzere
bak 0'dan küçük diyor. A üzeri 2n
ifadesinin sonucu pozitif a üzeri 2n + 1
ifadesinin sonucu negatiftir. Az önce
uygulamada konuşmuştuk. Bu 2n bir çift
sayıdır. Çünkü 2nin katı şeklinde.
Dolayısıyla negatif bir a sayısının çift
kuvveti pozitifken 2n + 1 formatındaki
sayılar tek sayıdır. A'da bir negatif
sayı olduğu için negatifin tek kuvveti
negatife eşittir. Negatifin çift kuvveti
pozitiftir. Negatifin tek kuvveti
negatiftir. Tamam mı? üslü sayılarda bu
çok önemli bir bilgi. Peki a pozitif bir
sayı olmak üzere a üzeri n ifadesinin
sonucu her zaman pozitiftir. Arkadaşlar
eğer bizim üstünü aldığımız aşağıdaki
sayı hani a üzeri n şeklindeki ifadedeki
şu a var ya bu a bu a pozitif bir
sayıysa bunun hangi kuvvetini alırsan al
feriştahı gelse sonuç pozitiftir. Mesela
ben eee 3'ün -235
kuvvetini alıyorum. -235. Come onon
yani. Ama ne olursa olsun ben bunu 1/3
üzeri 235 diye yazarım. Bu pozitif
olduğu için sonuç her zaman pozitif
çıkar. Pozitif bir sayının hiçbir
kuvvetini negatif yapamazsınız. Bir
kuvvet alarak negatif yapamazsınız.
Tamam mı?
Şimdi tik atağa da gidelim. Bunu
tamamladık. Bu tamam dedik. Bu da tamam
dedik. Buraya geldik. A pozitif bir
sayıysa A'nın 0 kuvveti şey 0ın a
kuvveti A'ya eşittir arkadaşlar. 0ın 3.
kuvveti demek 3 tane 0ı yan yana çarp
demek. Zaten 0 yutan eleman olduğu için
kendisini de yutuyor baba. Kendisi imha
ediyor herif. Dolayısıyla 0 x 0 x 0 hep
birbirini yuttu. 0 oldu. Peki niye
burada özellikle a pozitif ise diye
belirtmiş. Çünkü şöyle olsaydı mesela a
üzeri 0 üzeri -3 olsaydı kural gereği
ben bunu 1/0 üzeri 3 diye yazacaktım. Bu
da 1/0 olacaktı. Bir sayının paydasına 0
gelirse o sayı tanımsız olur.
Hatırlarsanız bölme işleminde 0a bölme
diye bir şey yoktur. Tamam mı? Bir şeyi
0a bölemezsiniz. Dolayısıyla a pozitif
diye burada özellikle belirtmiş. 1
sayısının her kuvveti 1'e eşittir. Her
kuvveti bakın pozitif negatif fark
etmez. Bir sayısının 3. kuvvetini
alsanız da cevap 1'dir. Bir sayısının -5
kuvvetini de alsanız cevap 1'dir.
İspatlayalım neden böyle olduğunu.
Pozitifte problem yok. 1 üzeri 3 1 x 1 x
1 demek de 1 üzeri -5. Oradaki eksinin
hiçbir anlamı yok hocam. Yani hiç mi bir
hatırımız yok? Hatırı yok tabii ki. 1/ 1
üzeri 5 diye yazabilirim kural gereği. E
1 üzeri 5 1 olduğu için bura 1/1 yapar.
1/1 de 1 olur.
Ne çok 1 dedim ya. 1dir 1 diye bir oyun
vardı eskiden. Peki bu da tamam. Eee -1
sayısının tek kuvvetleri -1'dir. Çift
kuvvetleri de +1'dir. Bunu zaten şey
biliyoruz. Negatiflerin tek kuvveti. Eee
şurada -1'imizi unutmuşuz arkadaşlar.
Şurada eksi yazacak. -1'in tek kuvveti
-1'dir. -1'dir.
-1'in çift kuvvetleri de kuvvet + 1'dir.
Tamam mı? Anlaştık mı? Nasıl -2'nin tek
kuvveti negatif oluyorsa -1'in tek
kuvveti de negatiftir. Nasıl -2'nin çift
kuvveti pozitif oluyorsa -1'in çift
kuvveti de pozitiftir. Burada tek fark
-1'in kuvvetleri hep 1'i verdiği için
burada eee sonuç değişmiyor. Ya 1
çıkıyor ya -1 çıkıyor. Tamam. Şuraya -1
yaptık. Notunuzu oraya alın. Peki bu
kavrama noktası da tamam. Bir örnek
yapalım isterseniz uygulama yapalım.
Uygulayalım bunları. Diyor ki, eee,
işleminin sonucu kaçtır? 9 üzeri 0. Her
sayının 0 kuvveti kaçtı? Tophaneli 1di
değil mi? 9 üzeri 0 1. 2'nin 1. kuvveti
her sayının 1. kuvveti kendisidir. Bura
2 böl -5'in 0 kuvveti burada eksi de
olsa fark etmez. Bir sayının 0 kuvveti
her zaman 1'dir. Çarpı -2 karesi 2
karesi 4 çift kuvvet olduğu için + 4.
Buraya da 4 yazdım. 3/1 zaten 3 demek. O
zaman burası 3 x 4 demek aslında. 3 ile
4'ün çarpımı da Allah izin verirse 12'ye
eşittir. Tamam mı? Peki şuradan da
cevaplara bakayım lan yanlış falan
olmasın. Eee, evet 12. Uygulama 3 ile
devam ediyoruz
ama bir çayımı içeyim abi yani. Dur,
sert başladık.
Tamam. Bir problem yok değil mi? Dersin
içindesin. Bak dersin içinde kalman çok
önemli. Ha öyle.
Yani eee matematik şeydir böyle e tam
odaklanmazsan bir an böyle gidersin
yani. Ne oluyor lan falan olursun yani.
Halatın ucu kaçtı mı geri tutması
zordur. Bakın ipin böyle tam ortasından
tutacaksınız. Böyle ucundan mucundan
tutmanızı istemiyorum. O yüzden ilk
sağlam başlayalım. Nasıl başlarsak öyle
gider. Tamam mı? Sağlam başlıyoruz.
Sağlam duruyoruz. Sağlam devam ediyoruz.
Amana ha. Aman ha. Tamam. Dersin içinde
güleceğiz, eğleneceğiz. Hatta 9.
sınıflara özel canlı yayınlarımız olacak
falan. Konuşacağız, her şeyden
bahsedeceğiz. Hiç hiç problem yok yani.
Liseye nasıl adapte olunur? Ben size
sosyal mesajlar da vereceğim. Yani 9.
sınıfta nasıl kıs tavlanır falan.
Onların hepsini onların hepsini abinin
size çözecek, hocanız size çözecek.
Merak etmeyin. Sadece derste ders
dışarıda dışarı. Derste ders ama
uygulama 3. 3 üzeri 2. Üzer 9'dur. 3ün
karesi 3 kere 3 9 -2nin 3. kuvveti bak
2nin 3. kuvveti 8'dir. Şurası 8 ve bu
-8. Çünkü buradaki eksiyi bu 3 artı
yapamıyor. Çünkü tek kuvvet. Şimdi bu -8
ya şurada bir eksi var zaten. Bir eksi
var. Bir de -8'in şöyle bir eksisi var.
O eksi eksiyi artı yapacak tabii ki. Onu
şimdi yaparız. Bölü. Ulan benim normal
renk bir şeyim yok mu ya?
He dur bakayım. Hıh tamam. Eee bölü 1in
4. kuvveti 1in 4. kuvveti 1'dir. 1in her
kuvveti 1'dir. -1in karesi de 2 çift
kuvvet olduğu için eksiyi artı yapar.
Burası da 1'dir. O zaman arkadaşlar
yukarısı eksi eksiyi şöyle artı yaptığı
için 8 + 7'den şey 9 + 8'den 17 aşağısı
da 2 yaptı. Aradığımız doğru cevap 17/2
oldu. Tamam.
Peki uygulama 4 ile devam ediyorum.
Şimdi diyor ki 2 üzeri a üssü sayısında
üs 2 arttırıldığında sayının değeri 24
artıyor.
Buna göre 3 üzeri a - a kare işleminin
sonucu kaçtır? Dur bir dakika. Şurada
bir şey ne? Ne demiş anlamadım ben. 2
üzeri a üssü sayısında üs 2
arttırıldığında
değer 24 artıyor. Bunu şey yapabilir
miyiz acaba? Tanıdık bir üslü sayı mı
bu? Yani burada böyle bir çıkarım
yapabilir miyiz? Üs 2 arttırıldığında
sayının değeri 24 artıyor. Mesela küçük
üslü sayılarla bir deneyelim. Mesela a
mesela a ise 2 üzeri 3 nedir? 8'dir. Üst
2 arttırıldığında ne yapar? 2 üzeri 5
yapar değil mi? 2 üzeri 3'ü 2 üzeri 5
yapmış oluruz. 2 üzeri 5 de 32'dir. E ne
oldu arkadaşlar? Ne kadar arttı? 24
arttı. 24 artar diyordu. Demek ki A'yı
bulduk. Kaçmış? 3'müş. Tamam mı? Eee,
böyle. Peki nereden hocam direkt 3
dediniz? Ben yazdım çünkü soruyu. Ben
yazdığım için ezbere biliyorum. Şaka
yaptım. Eee, yani ben yazdım onu da şaka
yapmadım da. Ya burada mesela 4'lere
falan gitmeyeceğimiz çok belli zaten.
Çünkü 2 üzeri 4 deseniz o 16. 2 arttır.
2 üzeri 6 64'lere falan gidiyor. Çok
agresif şekilde artıyor. O yüzden e
burada durduk. Yani A = 3'te durduk.
Tamam mı? Cevabımız eee yok lan. Dur
daha bir dakika A'yı bulduk. Daha
cevabımız falan değil şu an. A'yı
bulduk. A'yı 3 bulduk. O zaman hemen
şurada yerine yazıyorum. Şurada yerine
yazıyorum. 3 üzeri a. A yerine 3
yazarsam burası ne yaptı? 3 üzeri 3
yaptı. eki e a yerine 3 yazarsam burası
da 3 üzeri 2 yaptı. 3 üzeri 3 27'dir. 3
üzeri 2 de 9'dur. 27'den 9 çıkarttığımız
zaman da eee 18 mi kalacak? Aynen 18
kalır. Doğru cevabımız 18 olarak
bulunmuş olacak. Şimdi hocam bunu tahmin
etmeden nasıl yaparız diye soracak
arkadaş böyle cin cin tonik arkadaşlar
vardır belki. Hocam değer verdiniz falan
diyen arkadaşlar için orada biraz üslü
sayı işlemlerine girmek gerekiyor. A
sayı üst 2 arttırıldığında bu sayı a + 2
olur. 2 üzeri a + 2. Eski hali de 2
üzeri a'dır. Bunların birbiri arasındaki
fark 24. Buradan da yapabiliriz soruyu
üstlü denklem çözerek ama daha buralara
gelmedik. Bu soruyu buraya bu işlemleri
yapın diye koymadım ama meraklısına
çözeyim isterseniz. Ama az önce yaptığım
A'yı tahmin etme yeterli benim için. Ama
isterseniz çözeyim şurayı.
parçalayabiliriz. 2 üzeri a x 2 üzeri 2.
Daha gelmedim yalnız buralara. -2 üzeri
a = 24. Sonra 2 üzeri a'lar ortak olduğu
için burayı 2 üzeri a parantezine
alabiliriz. Birincisinde 4, 2incisinde 1
kalır. E= 24. Öyle bakma bana. Sen
istedin diye anlatıyorum. Bu 3 ile bu 24
sadeleşti. 8 yaptı. 2 üzeri a 8'e eşit
oldu. 2 üzeri a 8 ise 2'nin hangi
kuvveti 8'dir? 3. kuvvet. Demek ki a
kaçmış? 3. Ama ben bu işlemi yapmanı
istemiyorum. Sadece tahmin dışında bir
yöntem var mıydı diye soran arkadaşlara
cevap olsun diye bunu yaptım. Ama
normalde gerek yok buna ya. İleriki
konularda yapacağız bunu. Tamam mı?
Peki o zaman geldi senin sıran. Şimdi
durduruyorsun. Önce kendin çözüyorsun.
Cevaplıyorsun bitiriyorsun. Ondan sonra
en arkada PDF'in en arkasında, ders
notunun en arkasında cevap anahtarından
senin sıran 1. Senin sıran 1in
cevaplarını kontrol ediyorsun. Ondan
sonra yanlışın ya da boşun varsa benden
izliyorsun. Yanlışın ya da boşun yoksa
şöyle hızlıca bir göz at ne yaptığıma.
Sonra devam et bir sonraki sayfaya.
Tamam mı? Bir sonraki soruya yani. Şimdi
beraber konuşalım. Sen durdurdun çözmeye
başladın. Aşağıda verilen ifadelerden
negatif olanların kutucuğunu maviye,
pozitif olanların kutucuğunu da
kırmızıya boyayınız. Negatif olanları
maviye, pozitif olanları kırmızıya.
Aslında negatif olan kırmızıya daha
güzel olmaz mıydı? Neyse. Şimdi -2 üzeri
12 arkadaşlar. 12 bir çift kuvvet olduğu
için eksiyi artı yapacaktır. Dolayısıyla
pozitif olduğu için bunu kırmızıya
boyuyorum. Boyadım.
Eee, siz daha güzel boyayın. Ben böyle
boyadım. Geçtim. Şimdi, eee, şu sileyile
devam edelim. 2 üzeri -3. Arkadaşlar,
bir üst üslü sayının aşağı kısmı, üst
alınan kısmı biz buraya taban diyoruz.
Burası pozitifse üstüne bakmanıza gerek
yok. Bu her türlü pozitiftir zaten.
Önemli olan tabanı. Tabanı negatifse
konuşacağız. üste bakacağız ama tabanı
pozitifse üst negatifmiş, pozitifmiş
umurumda değil. Sonuç her zaman pozitif
yapar. Tamam mı? Buraya geldim. -2 üzeri
15. Burada bakın eksi şöyle vermemiş.
Gerçi verseydi de bir şey fark etmezdi.
15 tek sayı. Ama bu eksi parantezde
verilmemişse bu sayıyla alakası yoktur.
Önce şunun işaretine bakacağım. 2 üzeri
15'e. 2'nin 15. kuvveti 2 x 2 x 2 ç 2 çı
2 çarpı zaten pozitif. 2'yi 15 kere de
çarpsan pozitif 500 kere çarpsan da
pozitif. E bir de önünde eksi var. O
zaman bu negatif. Negatifse bunu maviye
boyayacağız. Şöyle boyadık. Peki
[homurdanır] buraya geldik.
-5 üzeri 16. 16 çift kuvvet. Eksiyi artı
yapacak. O yüzden kırmızıya boyuyorum.
Çok güzel. -3 üzeri 16. Şimdi burada
şunu diyecek olabilirsin. Aa hocam 16
kuvvet 16 çift sayı. Demek ki buranın
cevabı pozitif. Ama şöyle yazmamış.
Bakın bununla bununla bunun arasında bir
fark var. Ne fark var biliyor musunuz?
Burada 16 -3'e ait bir kuvvet. Burada 16
sadece 3'e ait bir kuvvet. Parantez
kullanımı üslü sayılar da çok önemlidir.
O yüzden burada önce 3 üzeri 16'nın
işaretine bakacağız. Pozitif önünde eksi
olduğu için negatif. Burası negatif
arkadaşlar. Tamam. Ama böyle yazsaydı -3
parantez içerisinde 16 deseydi o zaman
cevap pozitif olacaktı. Şimdi -7 üzeri
11 11 tek sayı. Dolayısıyla bu 7'nin
önündeki eksiyi artı yapamayacak. tek
sayı olduğu için negatif olacak. Negatif
olduğu için yine maviye boyayacağız. -5
üzeri 7 yine maviye boyayacağız. Çünkü
eksiyi pozitif yapamıyor. 7 tek sayı
olduğu için. İşte bunu kırmızıya
boyayacağız. Neden? Çünkü -4'ün parantez
içerisinde 10 kuvvet 10 çift sayı. Çift
sayı olduğu için -4'ü ne yapacak?
Pozitif yapacak. He cevabı ne bunun? Çok
büyük sayı bu. Fazla büyük yani. Bu bunu
yazamayız buraya. Yani yerimiz yetmez.
Yani çok fazla büyük bir sayı ama gerek
yok. Zaten işaret soruyor bize. Tamam
mı? Yani senin kağıtta aynı böyle
olmalı.
Böyleyse problem yok. Değilse eksiğini
dinle devam et.
Şimdi bir dikkat noktamız var
arkadaşlar. O dikkat noktamız şu. Eee
2/3'ün -2 kuvvetini alıyoruz. Biz bunu
şöyle düşünebiliriz değil mi? 2/3'ün -2
kuvveti için. Şimdi mesela 3'ün -2
kuvvetini alırken ne yapıyorduk? 1/3'ün
2. kuvvet. O zaman 2/3'ün -2 kuvveti
için 1/ 2/3'ün
2. kuvveti gibi düşünebiliriz. E burası
da takla atarsa ne olur? 3/2'nin
2. kuvveti. Çünkü rasyonel sayılarda 1/
atıyorum 1/7/6 demek 6/7 demek değil mi?
Takla rasyonel sayılardaki takla atma
kuralından dolayı, bölme kuralından
dolayı. E dolayısıyla bakın 2 üzeri 3
üzeri -2 3 üzeri 2 üzeri + 2 oldu.
Mesela buraya gelin. 1/2 üzeri -3 1/ 2
üzeri + 3. E dolayısıyla şu takla attığı
zaman 2 üzeri + 3. He o zaman bakın
bunlardan bir eee kazanım ortaya
çıkartacağız. Bir çıktı ortaya
çıkartacağız. Bu öğrenme çıktımız şu.
Demek ki a/ b şeklindeki gerçek
sayılarda eğer n yani kuvvet pozitif tam
sayı şeklinde ise bu kesir üzeri -1
takla atıyor. Bu kesir üzeri -n yine
takla atıyor. Eksiyi artı yapıyoruz.
Olay bu. Tamam mı? Yani rasyonel
sayıların negatif kuvvetini alırken
takla attırıyoruz. Bu kadar öğrenme
çıktımız bu. Şimdi bunu uygulayalım.
Yukarıda verilen eşitliklerden doğru
olanlarının yanına D, yanlış olanlarının
yanına Y yazınız diyor. Peki bakın 1/2
üzeri -3. Ne diyeceğim? Diyeceğim ki
takla atarsa 2/1 üzeri + 3 olur. Yani 2
üzeri 3. 2 üzeri 3 de 8. Bu ne demiş?
-8. Bu yanlış abiciğim. 8 diyecektin.
Kusura bakma. Aşağıyla devam ediyorum.
1/3 üzeri -2. 3/1 üzeri + 2. Bak hiçbir
şey yapmıyorum ha. 1/3'ü 3/1 yapıyorum.
Yukarıdaki eksiyi de artı yapıyorum.
Ondan sonra vur geç. 3ün karesi kaç? 9.
9 demiş. Seni tebrik ediyorum kardeşim.
Doğru. 5/2 üzeri -2. Ben bunu 2/5 üzeri
+ 2 diye düşünebilirim.
Bu da arkadaşlar 2/5'i 2 defa yan yana
çarp demek.
>> [homurdanır]
>> çarparsak 4/25 olur. Bakın burada
ondalıklı vermiş. O zaman ben
ondalıklıya çevireyim. Kesirli
ifadelerde bunu geçmişten eee
ortaokuldan biliyorsunuz. Kesirli
ifadeleri ondalık sayıya çevirebilmek
için paydalarını yani aşağı tarafı 10 ya
da 10'un e kuvveti yapmaya çalışırız.
Ben burayı 4 ile genişleterek 100
yapıyorum. Yukarısı 16, aşağısı 100
oluyor. Paydada 2 0 demek yukarıya 2
tane virgül at demek. O da 0,16 yapar.
Gerçekten 0,16 diyor. Doğru. Bu da
doğru.
3/2 üzeri -2. Şimdi buraya dikkat
edelim. Bu -2 bunun kuvvetinde değil. 2
üzeri -2'yi ayrı bir yerde yapacağım. 2
üzeri -2 demek 1/2 üzeri 2 demek. Yani
1/4 demek. O zaman aslında orası 3/ 1/4
demek. O da 3 aynen kalıyor. Rasyonel
sayılar kuralı gereği. 1/4'ü buraya 4/1
diye yazıyorum. O da 4 kere 3'ten 12
yapıyor. 12 demiş. Doğru demiş. Bu da
doğru. Bir tane yanlış 3 tane doğru var.
Ama 3 yanlış bir yanlış 3 doğruyu
götürür mü? Götürmez inşallah. Peki hadi
bakalım. Devam ediyoruz. Uygulama
altıyla nasıl sağ şey misin? Tansiyonun
mansiyonun yerinde mi? Sağ salim devam
ediyor musun derse? Daha yarım saat
falan oldu. Normalde bir sınıf dersinde
daha hatta bir başlangıçta bir 5 dakika
falan da konuştum. 25 dakika falan oldu
ama yoğun bir ders olduğunu
hissediyorsun değil mi? Böyle bir bir
değişik hissediyorsun kendini yani. Peki
işleminin sonucu kaçtır diyor? 2/3 üzeri
-1. Hemen hiç düşünmeksizin 2/3 yerine
3/2 yazıyorum. -1 yerine de 1 yazıyorum.
Hatta bunu da yazmıyorum. Çünkü bir
sayının 1. kuvveti yazılmaz. Kendisi
çünkü. Ne yazı? Manyak mıyım ben? Çarpı
-3/2.
Hemen onu -2/3 diye yazıyorum. Eksisi
ile beraber -2'yi de + 2 diye yazıyorum.
Tamam. Bu dursun. Art şurada çarpımız
var. 3/4 üzeri -1'i 4/3 üzeri + 1 diye
yazıyorum. Hatta +1'i yazmıyorum ama
bölü işaretini koyalım değil mi? Ayıp
olmaz. Şimdi -2/3ün karesi e bir kere
eksinin karesi + 2/3'ü kendisiyle
çarptığım zaman ne yapar? 2 x 2 4 3 x 3
9 O zaman burası şöyle oldu. 3/2 x 4/9
x şey + 4/3. Şimdi sen işlem önceliği
nedir bilen insansın. Burada çarpı var.
Burada artı var. Hangisi öncelikli? Yani
hangisinden başlamam gerekiyor? Çarpıdan
değil mi? Önce çarpacağım. Sonra
toplayacağım. Önce bu ikisini
çarpacağım. Çarparken dikkat edersen bu
3 ile bu 9 sadeleşiyor, 3 kalıyor. Bu 4
ile bu 2 sadeleşiyor, 2 kalıyor. Yani
orada aslında 2/3 kalıyor. Yanında da
4/3 var. Rasyonel sayılarda toplama e
tabanları aynı. Dolayısıyla ben bu
rasyonel sayıların üstlerini direkt
toplayabilirim. 4 ile 2'nin toplamı 6.
Paydasında da 3 var. 6/3 de 2'ye
eşittir. Aradığımız doğru cevap
2 olarak bulunmuş olacak uygulama 6'da.
Tamam.
[iç çeker] Peki şimdi senin sıran 2.
Durduruyorsun, çözmeye çalışıyorsun. Ya
hocam bana zor soru denk geldi. Siz
böyle basitleri çözüyorsunuz. Ondan
sonra bize zor soruyu iteliyorsunuz
demeyin. Ben de çözeceğim bunu. Ama
bazen eee bazen yapacağım bunu size.
Bazen de yapmayacağım. Yeri gelince
yapacağım. Yeri gelince yapmayacağım. O
benim işim. Karışmayın ona. Soruyu
çözmeye çalışın. Yapamazsanız falakayı
yatırmıyoruz. Şamar vurmuyoruz yani.
Yapamazsanız yapamadınız. Problem yok.
Ben zaten şimdi çözeceğim. Ama uğraş.
Tamam. Mutlaka uğraş. Şimdi diyor ki -4
2 3 8 16 ve 81 sayılarından 5 tanesi.
Burada kaç tane var la zaten? 2 4 6 tane
varmış ha. 5 tanesi aşağıda verilen
kutulara her kutunun içine farklı bir
sayı gelecek biçimde yerleştirildiğinde
eşitlik sağlanmaktadır. Buna göre hangi
sayı açıkta kalır?
Hım. 6 tane sayının 5 tanesini buraya
yerleştireceğiz. Zaten 5 tane kutu var.
Bir tanesi açıkta kalacakmış.
[ani nefes alır]
He. Peki şimdi bakalım
nasıl bir şey yapabiliriz. Şimdi bir
kere bak 16 var, 81 var, -4 var, eee, 2
var,
3 var.
Şimdi eee şunu güzel gördüm aslında. Bak
sen de güzel bunu görmelisin. Bak 2 ve
3.
Şimdi 2'nin 4. kuvveti 16'dır. Var
burada. 3'ün 4. kuvveti 81'dir. Var
burada. E -4 de var. O zaman aslında bu
sanki şöyle gibi geldi bana. Buraya 2'yi
yaz. Buraya 3'ü. Bu arada tam tersine de
yazabilirsin. Fark etmez. Buraya da -4'ü
yaz. Bu şöyle olmaz mı? Bunun cevabı
takla attırırsam 3/2'nin
4. kuvveti. Bu da ne demek? 3/2'yi
4 defa kendisiyle çarp demek. 3/2 çarp
3/2 çarp 3/2. 3'ün 4. kuvveti 81 2'nin
4. kuvveti 16. Bak eee
bak şimdi 2'yi kullandık. 3'ü kullandık.
16'yı kullandık. 81'i kullandık. -4'ü
kullandık. Hangi sayı dımdızlak kaçıkta
kaldı? 8. O zaman aradığımız doğru cevap
kaçmış? 8'miş. Tamam. Tam böyle bir
beceri temelli soruya göz kırpan bir
soru ama kolay. Yani olayı görürsek,
keşfedersek kolay. Şimdi üslü sayılarda
toplama çıkarma. Bu basit ya. Çarpma
bölme de basit de bu bu daha basit.
Paranteze alma gibi bir şey bu. Zaten
diyor ki üslü ifadelerde toplama ve
çıkarma işlemi yaparken hem tabanı hem
de üssü aynı olan sayılar ortak çarpan
parantezine alınabilir. Eee a x gerçek
sayı ve n bir tam sayı olmak üzere şimdi
bakın a x'in n kuvveti + b x'in n
kuvveti - c x'in n kuvveti olur. Ne
olur? Hemen göstereyim.
Bunların hepsinde x üzeri n kuvvet var
ya bunları x üzeri n kuvvet parantezine
alıyor gibi düşünün. X üzeri n kuvvet
buradan giderse burada kaç kalır? A
kalır.
Eee a + x üzeri n gider. Burada b kalır.
- x üzeri n gider. Burada da c kalır. O
zaman aslında yaptığımız olay bu. Ya
bunu yapıyoruz aslında. X üzeri n
parantezine alıyoruz. Şaka mı
yapıyorsun? Olay bu kadar. Mesela gel 7.
uygulamada ben anlatayım sana. Aşağıdaki
işlemin sonucunu bulunuz. Bak
3 üzeri 5 3 üzeri 5 3 üzeri 5. Hepsi
ortak. O zaman bunu 3 üzeri 5
parantezine alalım. Burada 2 kaldı.
Burada 4 kaldı. Topladım 6. Burada da 1
kaldı. Çıkardım 5. Yani 5 x 3 üzeri 5.
Bu kadar.
Buraya gelelim B şıkkına. Bak şimdi
burada 2 üzeri 11 var. Burada 2 üzeri 11
var. Burada 2 üzeri 11 var. O zaman ne
parantezine alınacak aslında? 2 üzeri 11
parantezine alınacak. 2 üzeri 11
parantezine alıyorum. Burada 3 kaldı.
Burada 6 kaldı. 9. 9'dan 5 çıktı 4.
Şimdi 2 üzeri 11 x 4.
Geleceğiz. Üslü sayılarda çarpmaya
geleceğiz. Ama bunu böyle
bırakabilirsin. Bunu böyle bırakırsan
sana asla kızmam. Ama bunu şöyle de
yazabilirsin. Bak 2 üzeri 11 x 4 de 2
üzeri 2 demek değil mi? Şimdi aslında
burada şu var. Netle lan beni. Aslında
burada şu var. 11 tane 2 ile 2 tane 2'yi
yan yana çarpıyoruz. 11 tane 2'yi yan
yana çarptığımız zaman burada 11 tane 2
var. E 2 tane 2 daha geldiğinde burada
kaç tane 2 olmuş olur? 13 tane 2 olmuş
olur. Aslında olay bu. Tamam. Bunu da
eee söylemek istedim sana açıkçası. Ama
2 üzeri 11 x 4 diye bıraksan da şu an
olur. Öğrenince bırakamazsın ama o zaman
gebertirim seni. Geldim buraya. Senin
sıran 3.
İşleminin sonucunu bulunuz.
Eee, tamam bulalım. Önce kendin
deniyorsun. Şimdi burada bir problem var
hocam. Yine kendi çözdüğünüz gibi basit
bir soru gelmemiş buraya. Burada 5 üzeri
4 var. Burada 5 üzeri 4 var. Burada 5
üzeri 3 var.
5 üzeri 4 5 üzeri 4 5 üzeri 3 nasıl
olacak
ya? Şey yok burada. E 5 üzeri 4 yok ama
aslında var. Bak bu 10'u 2 x 5 diye
ayırsan burada da 5 üzeri 3 var. Burada
5 üzeri 1 var. Aslında burada 4 tane 5
var. Yani ben burayı şöyle yazabilirim.
3 x 5 üzeri 4 ile oynamadım.
6 x 5 üzeri 4 ile de oynamadım. Buradaki
10'u 2 x 5 diye yazınca burası 2 x 5
üzeri 4 oldu. Şimdi artık aradığım
formata geldi. 5 üzeri 4 var. 5 üzeri 4
var. 5 üzeri 4 var. O zaman ben burayı 5
üzeri 4 parantezine alırsam burada 3
kalır. + burada 6 kalır. Eksi burada da
2 kalır. 9 2 çıkarttım 7. O zaman burası
5 üzeri 4 x 7 olmuş olur. Tamam mı?
Senin sıran e 3'ün cevabı 5 üzeri 4 x 7
ya da 7 x 5 üzeri 4. Artık hangisini
isterseniz.
Peki
şimdi dur bakayım neredeyiz bir bakalım.
Şöyle burayı hallettik. Burayı
hallettik.
Eee şu kavrama noktasında duracağım
arkadaşlar. Şu senin sıranı da
çözeceğim. Şu kavrama noktasında
duracağım.
Şurayla devam edelim. Gel
şurayı çözelim beraber. Şurayı beraber
çözelim. Şimdi olduğuna göre a değerini
bulunuz diyor. Şimdi dikkat ederseniz 3
üzeri x var. 3 üzeri x var. 3 üzeri x
var. O zaman 3 üzeri x ortak çarpan
parantezine alıyorum.
Burada 2 kalıyor.
+ burada 6 kalıyor. - burada da a
kalıyor. Eşittir burada da ne var? 4 x 3
üzeri x var. E 3 üzeri x denklemin her
iki tarafında da var çarpım durumunda. O
zaman Mortinze
8 - a = 4 yapar. Buradan da arkadaşlar
a'nın 4 olması gerektiğini gönül
rahatlığıyla bulmuş oluruz. Tamam.
Uygulama 8'in cevabı da 4'müş.
Güzel.
Eee, 9'la devam edelim. 2 üzeri x = a
olduğuna göre aşağıdaki zımbırtıyı 5 x 2
üzeri x - 1/2 üzeri -x işlemini a
türünden sonucunu bulunuz. Bir kere şunu
bir konuşalım lütfen. Bak şunu bir
konuşalım. Şimdi 1/2 üzeri -x. Bunu ben
1/2 üzeri x diye yazabilirim.
1/ 1/ olduğu için takla atar. 2 üzeri x/
1 olur. Yani 2 üzeri x olur. Yani
aslında şuranın cevabı 2 üzeri x. Yani
aslında 5 x 2 üzeri x - 2 üzeri x. Artık
bunları parantezle anlatmak istemiyorum.
Şöyle diyeceğim. Şimdi sen
bana bak. 5a'dan
a'yı çıkarttığın zaman bunu ne
yapıyorsun? Böyle şey mi yapıyorsun? A
parantezine alayım falan demiyorsun
değil mi? 5 tane a'dan bir tane a'yı
çıkartıyorsun. 4 tane a yazıyorsun.
Farkı yok. 5 tane 2 üzeri x'ten bir tane
2 üzeri x'i çıkartırsan 4 tane 2 üzeri x
kalır. Yani burası 4 tane 2 üzeri x.
Bunu böyle bırakabilirsiniz.
Eee, bunu böyle bırakamazsınız bu arada
kesinlikle. Çünkü 2 üzeri x'i a vermiş
soru zaten. Bakın 2 üzeri x = a olduğu
için ben buraya a yazarsam yanında da 4
çarpanı olduğu için burası 4 tane a
yapacak. Cevabımız 4a olacak. Tamam. Ben
sanki 2 üzeri x a olarak vermemiş gibi
böyle bırakabilirsiniz dedim. Nereye
bırakıyorsunuz? Bırakamazsınız. Peki
devam ediyoruz. Uygulama 10. Uygulama
10'u yapacağız abi. [homurdanır] Sonra
da senin sıran 4'ü yapacağız. Sonra
salacağım sizi. Söz veriyorum. Şimdi
diyor ki a x 3 üzeri 6 + b x 3 üzeri 7
toplamı hesaplanıp en sade biçimde
yazıldığında 3 üzeri 8 sonucu elde
ediliyor. A ve b pozitif doğal sayı
olmak üzere a + b toplamının
değerlerinden hangileri olabileceğini
bulunuz. Şimdi arkadaşlar bakın burada
bir paranteze alma işlemi yapacağız. Onu
da şöyle yapacağız. A x 3 üzeri 6 + b x
3 üzeri 7'yi 3 yani 7 tane 3'ün bir
tanesini ayırıyorum. 6 tanesini 1
bırakıyorum. O zaman şöyle oldu. Burası
a x 3 üzeri 6 + şurası 3b yaptı. 3b x 3
üzeri 6. Burada burayı da 3 üzeri 6
parantezine aldığım zaman a var 3b var.
Burada a + 3b oluyor. Şimdi arkadaşlar
bunun sonucunu yani 3 üzeri 6 x a +
3b'nin cevabını soru bize 3 üzeri 8 diye
vermiş. Buna 3 üzeri 8 demiş. Buranın
cevabı. Şimdi dikkat ederseniz burada 3
üzeri 6 var. Yani 3 x 3 x 3 x 3 x 3 x 3
var. 6 tane 3 var. E burada 6 tane 3 var
da öbürü durur mu lan? Orada da 8 tane 3
var çarpım durumunda. E arkadaşlar
dikkat edin. Bu bunu, bu bunu, bu bunu,
bu bunu, bu bunu, bu da bunu götürdüğü
zaman netle lan beni, bunları götürdüğü
zaman geriye ne kalıyor? Sol tarafta a +
3b kalmış oluyor.
Sağ tarafta da eee 3 2 tane 3 kalmış
oluyor. Yani 9 kalmış oluyor. E harika.
a + 3b kaça eşitmiş? 9'a eşitmiş. Çok
güzel. Şimdi a ve b nasıl sayılar?
Pozitif doğal sayılar. O zaman ben
burada a ve b'ye değerler vereceğim. Ne
verebilirim?
Pozitif doğal sayı dediği için 0
veremem. 1 vereyim. Mesela 1 vereyim 3b
8 olur. Olmaz. 2 vereyim 3b 7 olur.
Olmaz. 3 vereyim 3b 6 olur. B 2 olur.
Güzel. Bakın zaten 3'ün katı şeklinde
ilerliyor. 4 ver olmaz. 5 ver olmaz. 6
ver. 3b 3 olur. B 1 olur. 9 verirsen 3b
0 olur. B 0 olur. Ama pozitif doğal sayı
diyor. Yani arkadaşlar A ile B'nin 2
değeri var. A 3 B 2, A 6 iken B 1. O
zaman A + B toplamı 3 + 2'den 5'e de
eşit olabilir.
6 + 1'den 7'ye de eşit olabilir.
Şıklarda 5 varsa da olur, 7 varsa da
olur. Ama a + b değerini hiçbir zaman 3
yapamayız. Arkadaşlar o halde aradığımız
doğru cevap 1 ve 2 olacak. 1 ve 2. Tamam
mı canlarım? Güzel bir uygulama sorusu
dersin sonuna güzel denk geldi. Şimdi de
arkadaşlar bir güzel bir senin sıranla
bitiriyoruz. Şimdi kolay bir soru değil.
Üstünde düşünmemiz lazım. Zaten Marif
modelin bizden istediği de biraz o.
Şimdi ben bu derse kadar yaptığım her
şeyle size üslü sayılarla ilgili bazı
kazanımlar, bazı e bilinmesi gereken
şeyleri yükledim. Bu bilinmesi gereken
şeyleri bildikten sonra artık iş biraz
eee bu bildiklerimizi, bu argümanları
kullanıp bir şeyler üretmeye, bir şeyler
üzerinde kafa yormaya, analitik olarak
düşünme ve bunu problem çözme
becerisiyle birleştirme ihtiyacı
doğuruyor. Marif model tam olarak bizden
bunu istiyor. Senin sıran 4te bu
zihniyetle çok uyumlu bir soru. Beraber
okuyalım. Önce durdur, çözmeye çalış,
sonra da benden dinle. A, B ve C iki
basamaklı pozitif tam sayılar olmak
üzere 2a, 2 üzeri a + 2 üzeri b = 2
üzeri c eşitliğini sağlayan a, b ve
cğerlerini bulup bu tür eşitliklerin
sağlanabilmesi için geçerli olan özel
durumu bulunuz. Şimdi arkadaşlar bakın
2'nin bir kuvveti ile 2'nin bir
kuvvetinin toplamı 2nin bir kuvveti
nasıl eder? Mesela 2 üzeri 1 ile 2 üzeri
2'nin toplamı e yapar. 2nin kuvveti
değil. Eee, tek çift kuvvetlerde olmadı.
İkisi de çift olsa şöyle 16 + 4 20
olmuyor. İkisini de tek yapsam şöyle 8 +
2 10 olmuyor. Yani ikisini de tek yapsam
olmuyor. İkisini çift yapsam da olmuyor.
Eee birini tek birini çift yapsam da
olmuyor. Arkadaşlar bunun durumu şunun
da geçerli olabilir. Ancak burayı 2
parantezine aldığınızda buradan da ikili
bir şey gelebilmesi için bunların aynı
sayılar olması lazım. A'nın B'ye eşit
olmadığı hiçbir durumda 2 üssü 2nin
kuvveti olan 2 üsslü sayının toplamını
bir 2'nin üssü kuvveti yapamazsınız. Ama
mesela bakın 2 üzeri 4 ile 2 üzeri 4'ü
toplayın. Ne yapar? 16 + 16'dan 32 yani
2 üzeri 5. Bakın hep bir fazlası
geliyor. Görüyor musunuz? Mesela 2 üzeri
7 e 2 üzeri 5 ile 2 üzeri 5'i toplayın.
Ne yapar? E 32 + 32 64 yani 2 üzeri 6.
Aslında bu şuradan geliyor. 2 üzeri e a
ve 2 üzeri a'yı topladığınız zaman
aslında buradan 2 tane 2 üzeri a yani 2
üzeri a + 1 elde etmiş oluyorsunuz ki bu
da 2 üzeri c'ye eşit verilmiş soruda.
Demek ki her zaman ne oluyormuş?
Buradaki a ile b kesinlikle eşit
oluyormuş ve c bu a ve b'nin hep bir
fazlası oluyormuş. Bak bu A, bu B, C
bunların her zaman bir fazlası. Yani A
B'ye eşit. C de bunların her zaman bir
fazlasına eşit olmuş oluyor. Eee,
aslında şöyle diyeceğiz.
Eee, mesela evet şöyle diyeceğiz. Mesela
A atıyorum 4 ise 4 ise C'nin 5 olması
lazım. O zaman buraya C -1 yazacağız ki
şuraya şöyle -1 yazacağız ki eşit olsun.
Yani C bunların bir fazlası başka bir
değişkle bunlar yani A ile B C'nin her
zaman bir eksiği olacak. Dikkat edin bir
daha gösteriyorum. Bu A bak bu A bu A bu
da B bu da C. Gördüğünüz gibi A B'ye
eşit ve Cden her zaman bir eksikler. A
ile B C'den her zaman bir eksik. Yani a
= b. O da e= c - 1. Eşitliğini sağlayan
a b c değerleri sonsuz tanedir. Bir
tanesini yazalım. Mesela a yerine 12, b
yerine 12 yazalım. O zaman 2 üzeri 12 +
2 üzeri 12 yapar. Çok pardon. Ne oldu
oğlum bir anda? Bir anda nasıl bu kadar
büyüyebiliyorsun? İstesem yapamayacağın
bir şey ha. Eee o da ne yapar
arkadaşlar? 2 üzeri 12 + 2 üzeri 12. O
da 2 üzeri 10 3'e eşit olacaktır. İşte
A'nın, B'nin ve C'nin herhangi 3 tane
değerini de hesaplamış olduk. İki
basamaklı pozitif tek sayı dediği için
onun üstündeki sayıları almaya çalıştım.
Tamam mı? 1inci dersimiz burada bitti
arkadaşlar.
Eee, nereye kadar geldik? Şeye. Üssün
üssüne kadar geldik. Bir sonraki derste
yani üsslü sayılar 2inci derste üssün
üssüyle kaldığımız yerden devam
edeceğiz. PDF'leriniz, ders
çıktılarınız, ders notlarınız önünüzde
olacak. Hepsini benim gibi güzel güzel
not alacaksınız. Yazılması gereken
yerleri, düzeltilmesi gereken yerleri,
eklenmesi gereken yerleri, kendiniz
çözmeniz gereken yerleri, benden
dinlediğiniz yerleri, notları, kavrama
noktalarını, uygulamaları, senin
sıranları, dikkatleri, beceri temelleri,
öğrenme çıktılarını, her şeyi güzel
güzel not alacaksınız. Bu şekilde
ilerlediğiniz takdirde bunu yapamama,
anlamama şansınız yok. Tamam. Hepinizi
seviyorum. Kendinize iyi bakın. İkinci
derste görüşmek üzere.